today we're talking about new dead space
remake details war zone on mobile and
more
the dead space remake from ea motive is
now targeting an early 2023 release
while this doesn't constitute a delay
since the game was never given a public
release window it had been previously
reportedly targeting a 2022 release just
ahead of the dead space live stream
where the release window was announced
reports had circulated of the impending
kind of delay ea is said to be impressed
with the remake but wants it to be as
well received as capcom's resident evil
remakes as for the stream it featured an
in-depth look at some of the audio
systems used to create the creepy
atmosphere and things like the alive
system which has isaac struggling to
breathe the team will be hosting another
stream in may focusing on the art design
originally developed by visceral games
back in 2008 dead space is a fan
favorite and helped reinvigorate the
horror genre in games the remake is
being handled by ea motive the studio
behind star wars squadrons and it will
run on the frostbite engine and don't
worry i have the perfect thing to hold
you over until that game releases the
new dino safari dlc for lawn mowing sim
i don't know about you but that looks
like a roaring good time to me
however maybe you'd rather lay in bed
and throw stones at people in the gulag
while a new blog post on the official
call of duty website has confirmed that
call of duty warzone is coming to mobile
unfortunately though the post is light
on information this confirmation comes
after a report from december 2021 hinted
at a 2022 release date for the warzone's
mobile version tom henderson tweeted
that the game was anticipated for launch
this year citing its addition to the
playtest cloud database warzone will
mark the second call of duty battle
royale on mobile devices joining the
mode built into the standalone call of
duty mobile there's no word yet on
whether or not this new mobile war zone
will be a part of that app or launch as
a separate download and while we're on
the subject of handheld games let's talk
about steam deck microsoft has detailed
which of its games are compatible with
valve steam deck with only a handful of
titles being unsupported due to
incompatibility with anti-cheat software
in a post on steam microsoft explained
that each developer in xbox game studios
is responsible for ensuring
compatibility with the steam deck but
that priorities at each might force this
to take longer than expected the upside
is that many games are already
compatible with a large majority having
verified statuses already from valve in
terms of games that will not work at all
on the steam deck halo infinite and the
master chief collection are both
unsupported as well as gears of war 5
and microsoft flight simulator 10.
unlike bungie which says players
attempting to play destiny 2 on steam
deck might result in a ban microsoft
hasn't detailed what exactly might
happen if you try to get games like halo
working on steam os so proceed with
caution alright the weekend's here so
let me know what you're playing and head
over to twitter and tweet me some
screenshots i'd love to see your
gametography like this moment from our
very own aaron sampson
see you next week